it's the end of the year and time for me
to be mystic Greg again with my
predictions from what will happen in the
next 12 months but first how did I do
that let's take a look we won't be
leaving the EU at the end of March I
believe Parliament not necessarily the
government would decide to extend
article 50 secondly there will be a
second referendum in 2019 the people's
vote will happen and horror of hollars
the Daily Mail or support staying in the
EU
I don't believe Mrs May will be prime
minister this time next year and more
controversially I think Jeremy Corbyn
will also be on his bike by next
December now I know everyone has had the
b-word up to here so apologies if my
predictions are dominated by Bex it but
I'm not going to be betting on this love
life well I'm blessed I was
spectacularly wrong yeah so pretty
pathetic there however on my other two
predictions it was 100% right on one
that was to either May is no longer
Environment astir and almost right on
the second the Jeremy Corbyn would be
gone by December so here we go for 2020
I'm going to start with a football
prediction England will win the European
football championships this summer
secondly I'm predicting that although we
will leave the EU in January we will by
the end of the year be involved again an
almighty battle with the EU over terms
and leaving without a deal we'll be back
on the table thirdly I'm predicting that
Corbin will be replaced as Labour leader
by someone who will be well to the right
of him and there's an element of sanity
would have returned to the Labour Party
and finally the US Senate will acquit
Donald Trump him but he won't win the
presidential election in
[Music]
okay well I personally am less plastic
less optimistic I reckon camp will win
you won't be impeached fully as for the
EU situation say he wouldn't be don't
you be impeached fully yeah what will
happen is he'll lose the election I
think he's gonna win
I've yeah as the others say Trump wins I
think you're right I think this is
damaged trumpet blows oh no I think he
just makes it look like the
establishments against them stand in the
forest all the time I know there's a
company called Moody Analytics in
America and they've called it's a
financial institution they've called
every election right since 1980 and they
have done three kind of different
scenarios and Trump wins every single
time even if Mike Bloomberg gets the
Democratic because what is what Moody's
are saying is it's the financial if the
economy is good and people will vote on
what the firm is working as for the EU
situation well it took us three and a
half years to negotiate an 11-month
transition period and Boris Johnson's
next plan is to negotiate a permanent
deal so basic math says that he's not
going to get that done in 11 months on
top of that the deal that he's signed to
take us out of the EU says that we have
to we're under a legal obligation to
negotiate the sort of deal described
from the political declaration that
political declaration says we will have
comprehensive deep regulatory
cooperation with the EU what that means
is following the rules of the EU but no
longer having any say-so he said one
thing in his manifesto and one thing in
the legally binding withdrawal deal that
is a recipe for chaos so yes you're
entirely right there about the football
I'd love to listen my heart says it I
just I suppose I've been around too long
where they just come up short because I
96 win football game home and Gaza
missed that goal by about that much if
that have got my I hope you're right but
remember both semifinals and final
Windley which is what the huge boosters
in absolutely huge risk and you think
did you name someone for the Labour
leadership you didn't did you
no I just think I can to the right I
think
if the Labour Party chooses anybody
collide then I think they're gonna be in
terrible it isn't they still even now
even this many days after the election
they still haven't realized why they
lost the stones they still don't
understand whether they're blaming
brexit and the media they're playing a
biased media and my families didn't vote
I love that it was the didn't where does
this end but somebody like they can die
my fear somebody like Rebecca long
Bailey will get ilysm she's an acolyte
of Corbin she believes in his no I want
a fantastic Labour Party I want a tough
Labour Party
I want to Labour Party's that can win
back the north and heartless because
that the party was it was it win a
second term I didn't say that what I
said was working-class people deserve a
Labour Party that works to protect the
big after them that's what exists and if
Rebecca really becomes the leader Labour
Party exactly if you if you sculpt a New
Labour leader out of the mold of the
Labour leader that delivered the biggest
defeat for the Labour Party in 84 years
you are destined to lose again and I
personally do not find you ten more
years apart do you think I think for me
and I also have agree on the Labour
Party the biggest difficulties they've
got a shift and moved to believing in
proportional representation because they
probably will never win again otherwise
yeah but the simpler shift they have to
do is to listen to the people who are
voters and that's the simplest thing
they can do next time and I mean I don't
know but you guys but I really fancy
Jess Phillips I fancy listen Andy I
think both of them ID replace a good
wing back the Heartland yes are in a
period of reflection now which means
just basically staring into the the
dregs that tea leaves cook I'm gonna
give my predictions Nostradamus Greg
you're going to give up flying and go
from our by catamaran well you're gonna
you're gonna revive the people's vote
campaign
Nick Nick is going to declare himself
non-binary yes semi you're going to
become the paid spokesman for the ERG
group of course Yeah right I'm going to
be what about you you're gonna fill your
deep freeze I'm gonna make turkey soup
so what happens in the more just
wrangling over breakfast it then go
through the whole home of the I think I
think you'll get a six nine months
it'll-it'll garden under the radar but I
think coming into the yeah I don't see
how you can get it they're committed by
they're now putting into the into a
parliamentary act they committed that we
will have a deal by the end of the year
and I don't think you'll get it and then
it's your back to that miserable
argument about whether or not we leave
you know and I'm not saying I've had
this conversation but why create a
needless red line
why create an appoint list cliff edge
when you suggestin a we've got brexit
done everyone can relax we don't have to
talk about it ever again because that's
the deal they do before I know what that
they would do more to the election
Toni's candidates only candidate or
anymore but if first no but if those
candidates are stood in the Torrey areas
that would be they would have an option
it's the most pointless piece of
posturing I've ever seen putting into
law that we have to leave the EU we have
to leave the end the transition payable
no matter what in December it makes zero
sense if he has a majority of eighty
meaning he can change it on a whim he's
to be cannot be stopped he has absolute
power that's why it's that's why I
believe it's what they promised the
election party but you also said that no
deal will be back on the table and I
think you're right in the sense that I
don't think we leave with no deal but
but be no Boris can do that now this is
this is his trump card no it can't that
couldn't be played when mrs. main was in
power but now it can't be